so the best thing you can do if you're
trying to get into a mentorship
relationship you ask one question you
got to ask Robert Kiyosaki one yeah
what's the one question that you want to
ask him and then don't ask another
question because that's what people will
do they'll come back and say oh what
about this and what about that do the
work on the first question that he gave
you an answer for and then go home and
actually do the work and if you get a
result then you can come back and ask
the second question hey I asked you this
I did this I've got five Apartments man
thank you from your advice now I'm
struggling with this he's much more
likely to give you a second answer
because of the work you're doing the
first one or if the advice didn't work
make sure that you try it a hundred
times it wasn't just you made one phone
call and it didn't work until the end of
the advice because we tried it a hundred
times you showed the effort and he's
willing to answer a second question